у на учень не падали до варшавої brute
долі 400 солдатів бундесверу
їх не головне завдання вид проти ти
взаємодій із польськими колегами
у найбільших історія пульс чинів
чайник зайди на тридцять одну тисячу
скронь x24 держав у тому числі з
україни до грузії бажати від його била
треба щось кілька за дейни хуциев
на чайник солдатик то у нини заповнювати
на статевих стадіонах до варшави ми
краще робимо свою роботу я думаю зараз
я провокація
совок вона не забув я за нею, щоб пам'ять
про наші броні сили хуторі будинки житлові
спробувати у маневру за 93 тисячі один
з бойової техніки засіки танки і такі
кліків трм і 12 кораблів союзники
мати протестують і нападуть результату без
офіційного калоші невинним a-gps
яндекс крем і піди на сході україни
треба працювати ще Росії може ай ем на
кутова ти на під на скіни фланг альянсом
в Москві однак такі наново виглядаю
кидає мовляв саме на вч вони анаконда
поштою
завантажу тобі спати і росії батько правді
масштабніше навчання
alavann її реакції україна то за одного
боці на дарма ви польщі то яндекс кіно
європейських держав про завантаження ніж
відходи з Росії озвучували цілі ціни
монети російської армії які бувають у 2
чит ричі наймасштабніші за анаконду за
helirussia зал учневі свій ритм помру
каліків знати історію чоловік руб це
хіт побачити німецький експерт весна чаю
все-таки троянду так мабуть пам'ятайте побачу
ловіть скронь їх та цін на вигляд навколо
побої виник би 100 ті телиця ви-то
перебувала під контролем політики чого на
думка аналітика
зараз немає і че за фігню експерти весь
означає чуючи в нато ненсі виступала за
проведення на чай головний аргумент
противники у демонстрація сили наслідний
кордону касу тему складати
видно було не видно sense росії та
завершити маневр і планує 17 червів за
33 дні до початку саміту нато у варшаві
[музика]